scientists have studied a lot of
pregnant animals in space including
salamanders fish and rats but not humans
over 60 women have traveled to space yet
none more pregnant during the trip let
alone gave birth while floating in zero
gravity but with talk of future space
colonies and cities on Mars there's a
good chance that one day humans will
give birth somewhere beyond Earth and
that brings up some interesting
questions what will it be like how will
space babies look and ultimately how
will giving birth in space be different
the most obvious difference is the low
gravity environment and without the aid
of Earth's gravitational pull it might
make it more difficult for the mother
when it comes time to push the baby out
plus if one day women lived in space
permanently some of the risks of
pregnancy would be much greater than on
earth for one without the stress of
Earth's gravity her bones lose density
studies show that astronauts for
instance lose one to two percent of
their bone density for every month spent
in space and that would be especially
concerning for giving birth because the
pelvis could fracture in the process in
fact doctors recommend that women with
brittle bones avoid a natural birth
altogether which can mean births in
space would be left to other methods
[Music]
that Scott Solomon an evolutionary
biologist and professor at Rice
University he walked us through what
space might do to generations of humans
born in low gravity environments we
already know that the way we give birth
influences our Anatomy for example the
size of our heads is restricted by the
size of our mother's birth canal with
more c-sections that could lead to
larger and down-the-road larger heads
wouldn't be the only major change we may
also change color says Solomon that's
because in space we have less protection
against harmful space radiation like
cosmic rays so to counteract that
we may evolve new types of skin pigments
like the melanin that protects our skin
from ultraviolet sunlight on earth that
could mean that future generations
living beyond Earth will evolve to have
different skin colors the more melanin
you have the darker your skin so Solomon
predicts that people living in space may
develop darker skin over time but he
says these changes might take centuries
or millennia for enough time for many
generations of women to give birth in
space eventually to be different enough
from people on earth that we would
consider them to be different species
but for now we just need one very brave
woman to pave the path
[Music]